He is right why let us change the subtitles
I'm So Fucking Tired M8
Look At This Face
Look How Sad He Is
*facepalm*
We're back on square one, Youtube.
Bravo, Bravo. You did it.
(Intense PØLSE) Is this how it's gonna be now
Ill just have to make a video.
Everytime theres a problem.
Cause otherwise no one gives a shit
Also, I've been enjoying my new shitty youtube
(Zoom) Buuu
Lets have a little look at the comments shall we.
Eyy
Oh, Caras Vlogs
Pewds there is a secret ending I want to tell more!
Seven hundred and Eighteen likes..
(Silence)
Well it was a great comment
Made by a
Pretty lady (Zooms in on Photo)
Marzia, I'm just making a point
This comment is obviously fake
Why are 700 of you like this comment
There's another one identical to it.
626 likes
And..
Guess what?!
THERE'S ANOTHER IDENTICAL
THE ORIGINALCOMMENT
These fuckers, they take comments that got a lot likes they copy and paste them.
And boom, hey... hey
...a cute girl in the picture...
I never had an interaction with a lady before.
Oh boy, here I come
That was a funny comment. Here I, here I go! Here I go.
*Click*
Ahhh.
Shiiiiit.
Are you guys that pathetic? Are you that fucking stupid?
Can y'all stop thinking with your dicks for one fucking second?
Look at what's underneath it.
PewDiePie, if you are reading this, you are so lucky
"Go to: special surprise for all of you"
Let's loo...you know what? You can track the data of these links.
Let's see how many of you fucking idiots clicked on this shit.
six thousand...
And...that's counting ......from yesterday.
*Slow clap*
*keeps clapping* That's good. That's good, that's good.
I mean, come on...
You ho- you horny bastards are ruining my channel, alright?
"Cara Vlogs". First of all, why don't you call yourself like a normal fucking name like "Clara Vlogs" or some shit.
There's different variations of these. Alright? I've seen them.
"Cara Vlogs", "Sarah Vlogs", "Patricia vlogs"
Okay, stop.
"IF YOU SUB ME, I WILL SUB BACK WITH 34 ACCOUNTS."
Hey, let's give it a go.
Just fucking kidding, you fucking bitch, alright?
I don't even know where to begin in this mess.
First of all, oh my god, I've said this for years.
I've said this for longer than I begged for the Diamond Play Button.
This is for YouTube..
Why the f... why the hell... wh-why...?
Why can people create accounts with your name in it?
A couple years ago, before the Google+ ap...apocalypse..
You could have one name per person. There could not be two PewDiePies, only one.
Who thought it was a good idea to let that be a thing? -_-
What the fuck are you guys thinking? Like, do I have to say this? Like I've said it for years.
No one listens at YouTube at these sort of things. Why can they do this?
It is mind-blowingly stupid.
Yes, there is a checkmark by my name.
Not everyone knows about that. Just don't let them create a character with my account. Just don't let 'em do it.
People think this is me. Six thousand
people, every day think that's me.
Alright, take that in a month.
Six thousand, three hundred. That's roughly two hundred thousand a month, which calculates to two million a year.
And this is just one channel. We'll click on this link...
What happens? Ooooh, "gifts for my subscribers!" We all know there is a lot of
young kids on YouTube who don't know better.
They see this and they think, "Oh my god, PewDiePie wants to give me a gift."
Well, not my fans 'cause they're
they're not fucking idiots. But I imagine other people are. What do we- what do I want?
I want a galax- I have one. Wait you get A THOUSAND GALAXY S7? Thats a lot of S7 Phones Man...
That is a tempting offer.
I was gonna say yes to one, but now I
get a thousand. Oh, theres a-
there's even a chat here. "Is this really
working?"
"Die in a fire"
"Is it really working?"
"Yep it works, it's for his subscribers only." They obviously put in a lot of effort into making this seem real.
Alright, okay. I want an iPhone, give me an iPhone.
which-ooh. I can select colors, that's pretty generous.
"Proceed for human verification."
Oh! Never mind! "Download an app to prove that you are human." 4 of the offers to unlock the content. Okay, Tesco vs. Argos....
So, it's basically advertisements. You're filling in advertisements. Making these people money.
"Kill yourself." Another thing that blows
my mind how stupid it is
and this is something not just me, but a lot of youtubers have pointed this out
for years!!
If there's a really stupid comment that
you want to maybe explain something to...
If you reply to that comment, their
comment will get bumped,
while your comment will get buried. Why doesn't it just show my answer
underneath like this. Is that so hard?
Why does these things take years to implement? This thing that YouTube
essentially is closing their eyes on for years.
I am so tired of it, and sick of it and
I just want my comments to be
functioning.
They're not.  (Mocking voice) PooDiePie, you're such a crybaby, why do you care?
Well, comments is the main thing, feedback, I get from my fans. I want to understand
what they think and what they say. If the comments gets abused,
then I can't use it. Last time, I had to
turn them off just hoping YouTube would
do something. And I gave them a bunch of feedback that time. That was, this was
years ago, by the way, I said "Moderators..."
I said  "don't let people have the same
name, don't let people post links."
Why would you give people more freedom to post links? Why would you need to link
something in the comments? Who didn't realize that's a terrible fucking idea?
We have this broken ass system that never fucking works, what should you do with it?
Oh! I know! Let's give them more freedom! That's the google way! *Clapping*
I've called to action before. I said "Hey fans, can you help me clean out the comments?"
"Can you help me flag or report?"
It doesn't work like that. A lot of these
features does exist on YouTube.
There are ways to have moderators, but it's so inefficient. No one knows about it.
On twitch, however, it's so easy. "Slash mod whatever person"; they can help clean out
The chat, not a problem.
I'm one person with 45, 46 million people.
Am I supposed to just moderate that
Myself?
When clearly, I have a ton of fans who
could help me out? Why- people can add subtitles (Heyyyy  c;)
Literally, there's the option for anyone to put subtitles on my videos,
Without any moderation.
Why can we give them that freedom but not moderate the comments?
Can we please just have moderated
comments, please?
YouTube, I'm begging you, it's such a
simple solution. Which what I understand,
for you seems to be a complicated
problem.
I'm sick of this. I love you YouTube, but
you don't listen...
Goodbye, I'm just gonna go this time.
Yeahh, all right, well, that was my little rant. And got a little worked up there and...
Thank you for leaving a like, appreciate it.
Tweet the hashtag:
#MakeCommentsOnYouTubeNotSoShitPleaseJustAddModerators   - Can we make that a trend?
[thumbs up]
[you...]
[kisses fist]
(Fist hits camera)
Stay awesome, bros.
It's- It's been bothering me for so long now
I've been trying to find solutions to it
I've been hoping that it would get better
I was hoping YouTube would try to figure a way out
but it- it doesn't seem like it, and... umm, I'm just sick of it
They're not coming back, uhh, this time around
And I hope you understand my decision of doing that
I wouldn't say it as we'd lose something
I would say it as.. taking the next step in the right direction.